what happens when you put a paper  origami swan into the clockworks dr joe  selected three white paper origami swans  each weighing 29 grams the first paper  swan was placed into scp-914 on the  setting rough the output produced was  one crumpled piece of white paper  weighing 29 grams the second paper swan  was placed on the setting one to one and  the clockworks produced one paper  fortune teller resembling those popular  with children it had no writing on it  the final paper swan was placed in on  the setting fine the output was one  paper model of a trumpeter swan the same  size and weight as the original origami  this paper model was anatomically  correct in every way down to the  impossibly intricate details of its  internal organs there were no other  anomalous properties